my great pleasure to introduce junha
Jiang uh one of the fellows this quarter
and a graduate student at Columbia
University
um I think children's work like very
clearly falls into the core uh you know
Mission and focus and motivations of the
program there's a number of exciting
works on problems at the intersection of
optimization sketching Dynamic data
structures using this to solve some of
the you know key motivating problems I
talked about in the beginning of the
week you know things like linear
programming semi-definite programming
Dynamic versions of linear system
solving and in today's show we talk
about a matrix data structures this
naturally builds upon a number of the
things we've seen before where we've
talked about sketching and dynamic graph
algorithms this talk will talk about you
know some analogs of these Dynamic graph
algorithms or dynamic problems for more
linear algebraic problems which in turn
I use some of the sketching techniques
that were introduced earlier and you
know have had a big impact you know
through optimization methods so thank
you very much I look forward to talk
thank you so much for the invitation and
thank you all for coming early in the
morning today I'm going to talk about
Matrix data structures but before we go
to Matrix data structures let me first
give you a little higher picture about
how it fits in this whole boot camp so
the motivation of many of the Matrix
data structures I will cover today
actually come from uh sleep speeding up
optimization algorithms so we know that
there are many algorithms for
optimization problems they are iterative
and whenever you have an iterative
algorithm we can measure its total
running time as the number of iterations
times the cost per iteration I very much
mean amortized cost per iteration here
and there has been many extensive
research on trying to bound a smaller
number of iterations many of which we
heard in yesterday's talk but apart from
that there's also the other side of
research that tried to decrease the cost
per iteration and the observation behind
this research is that many these
iterative algorithms organization
algorithms are actually very robust and
many variables are actually changing
pretty slowly so instead of recomputing
all the variables from scratch into
duration which can be expensive we can
use data structures to implicitly
maintain many solutions and then in each
direction we just perform a faster
update to it and this will improve the
cost per iteration
and recently there has been a renewing
interest in trying to improve the cost
per iteration which leads to many
state-of-the-art algorithms there are a
lot of graph algorithms and many of them
use graph data structures and graph
linear algebra that were covered in the
previous lectures and but for
organizations with General matrices many
of them will use Matrix data structures
and that will be the topic of my talk
today and just if you're curious on the
two figures on the right here are made
by Dolly by open AI because there are
some very complicated optimization
problem behind that so I think it would
be a good fit to fit them here
okay so now let me first Define what are
the Matrix data structures that we will
consider today so we'll consider this
very simple prototype problem where we
wanted to maintain some Matrix function
under certain updates to The Matrix M
and then we wanted to support certain
queries to this Matrix function FM so
let me give you some examples it can be
basically any Matrix function for
example it can be the inverse or it can
be the Matrix multiplied with some fixed
vector or maybe you wanted to maintain
the large scores of the Matrix or it can
even be the solution of some
optimization problem that involves amp
and there are also many different types
of updates
it can be an element update to The
Matrix or update a column a row or a low
rank update to The Matrix and there are
also many different type of queries we
can query an element of this Matrix
function FM or we could query column row
of the Matrix or maybe we wanted to give
you a query Vector every time we make
the query and I want you to Output The
Matrix Vector product
okay and sometimes in the query we will
allow approximations because it very
much depends on what is the optimization
problem that we need so for different
algorithms it will give a different sort
of interface when we're designing data
structures and because it allows
approximations we can use all the
randomized sketching techniques that
Michael talked about and also because
whenever we use Randomness we need to
consider on the adversarial update model
this is because these optimization
algorithms are in some sense inherently
adversarial because the update that you
receive in the next iteration will
depend on the query outputs that you
gave in previous iterations so basically
your Randomness are somehow like
inherently leaked in previous iterations
so you need to take this into account
when we're designing data structures and
these two are some recurring theme um
when people are constructing data
circuits okay so now let me first give
you a very very simple example of one
Matrix data structure so we just wanted
to maintain the entire inverse Matrix of
our Matrix M under rank 1 updates of
form eov transpose
so what should we do if we do it naively
each iteration we just recompute the
universe and that would take into the
Omega time which Omega is fast measures
multiplication exponent exponent but we
can do it faster using this Woodbury
identity I think many of you might not
be familiar with it but it will come up
multiple places in my talk today so I
think it's good to show it up here in
the second slide and I also made a
little figure of this so what it says is
that basically if we wanted to compute a
low rank update inside our inverse we
can take it outside of the inverse and
there will still be a rank 1 update so
how to prove this if you just multiply M
plus UCB on the right you will see that
it equals to an
um like it just cancels out okay so when
we use this Woodberry identity we can
see that the main bottleneck is just a
matrix Vector multiplication so it would
only take and squared time for both
updated
okay
so next let me give you a small like
overview it's going to be a very
incomplete list of some of the recent
um better optimization algorithms that
use Matrix data structures one big part
of the organization problems that I will
cover today are chronic Pro organization
where the formulation is we wanted to
optimize some linear objective under
some linear constraints and with the
actual hard constraint that the variable
X should be inside some convex call the
simplest and most well-known example of
conic programming is linear programming
where the cone is just a negative
portion and it's equivalent to say that
we want the variables to be negative and
the current best algorithm for square
dense LP where this constrained Matrix
roughly have the same number of
constraints as the number of variables
matches the current fast matrix
multiplication times
that plus into the two and one over 18.
and these algorithms heavily use faster
data structures and there's also the
other setting where where in the flat
case where there are much fewer number
of constraints comparing to the number
of variables and in this case the
current best running time is in the post
D to the 2.5 so when n is large enough
one is larger than D to the 1.5 this
basically matches the input size
uh but there are also other iconic
programming
um for example another well-known one is
semi-definite programming where the cone
is just the set of positive
semi-definite matrices and there's also
some of squares optimization where the
code is set of some of squares
polynomials and the state of the art
algorithms all use faster data
structures
but there are also like roughly speaking
Matrix data structures can be applied
for other regression problems or even
for some non-convex organization
problems if you have some other
preference that you have in mind that
also fall into this category you're
welcome to shoot me an email offline and
then I will add that later
okay
so I won't yeah
um
what if the constraint is very large
so actually in this formulation it
doesn't make sense when it's too large
yet you should have less number of
constraints in the number of variables
but it's just this formulation this
equivalent if you have inequalities in
the lp as in that case you can have more
constraints
okay let me continue thank you for the
question uh I won't be able to cover all
these problems today clearly so today I
will focus on two upper rounds the first
problem is linear programming because
it's so well known uh and it's sort of
very typical example of how to apply
data structures and the data structure
for linear programming is inverse
maintenance and hopefully after today's
talk you will at least get to see how to
get uh into the Omega time for the
current matrix multiplication exponent
and after that I also wanted to cover
this problem about Dynamic lead squares
regression not only because it's a very
simple algorithm that can fit in one
talk but also because it uses some
techniques that are also very useful in
other problems like online levels for
sampling and JL sketch so I think it
would be nice to cover these techniques
here so that's the first two parts and
then after that I will provide you with
some matching conditional lower bounds
for these two upper rounds
so let's get started with
Universal maintenance for LP but in fact
before I move on
to the data structure part I will need
to First give you a little very brief
overview about interior Point methods
for LP because we are designing data
structures for the algorithm so we need
to know what is the interface what is
our what is the data structure problem
that we care about
um so this will be a very very brief
overview I will hide a lot of details
under the rack and just in this
afternoon you will give a much more
detailed to our lecture about ipn so you
can think about my slide here as a
little teaser for his lecture this
afternoon
okay
so we will consider this form of LP
where we have a primal formulation and a
dual formulation and then this is the
Primal feasibility constraint this is
the deal feasibility constraint and we
further require that the Primal
variables X and the Dual deal slack
variables X as to be both in the
negative
and then there's this complementary
slackness condition that basically says
at optimality on every single coordinate
your Primal variable should be zero or
your slack variable should be zero and
any X and S that satisfies the Primal
constraints the Dual constraints and
complementary status will give us the
Optimal Solutions because this is the
all the equations that you need to get
the optimal but this is hard to solve
directly because this is a quadratic
term and we don't know how to solve that
efficiently
so what we do in IPM is that we sort of
relax this complementary slackness to
say that we don't require x times s
equals to zero we just require it equals
to some other number mu which is a
positive number and by the way the dot
here means coordinate wise product
um and then once you decrease mu from
some large number to zero it will
correspond to a pause in our feasible
region and what does the algorithm do it
basically starts from some large mu zero
and the change iteration it gradually
decreases mu so that it moves along
approach the optimal solution
um
okay
and in situation what we do because we
wanted to decrease this mu so we will
compute some update Vector to the MU
which I'll call a Delta Mu here and we
wanted to make sure our new point which
is X and Y and S Plus this Delta steps
still satisfy the central plus equation
and then that will give us this system
here uh you will see that the second and
the third one are actually easy to see
if you just plug in X Plus Delta X and
then S Plus Delta s here but for the
first equation we are getting rid of the
second order term so if you just look at
it here there should be a Delta x times
Delta s here and let me also explain the
notation the capital x here means a
diagonal matrix where it's diagonal R is
a vector X and similarly for capital S
this is a pretty standard notation in
the IPM literary term
uh and I also wanted to mention maybe
some of you have heard that ipms will
take a new test of each iteration so
this is equivalent to a Newton step even
though I'm deriving it from
complementary slackness so if you relate
to yesterday's talk IPM would be a
second order optimization algorithm
okay uh and I also wanted to say
um it takes written iterations in order
to decrease your Duality Gap or like
optimize your optimal value by half
so in the end it will take like written
Times log one or absolute iterations I
want to explain why we got written here
but I think you will cover this this
afternoon
okay
and we have equivalently write out these
equations in The Matrix form and it will
give us this Matrix here so
the takeaway of this slide is in IPM in
every single iteration all we wanted to
do is to solve some linear system where
the S and X will depend on your current
variable so they will change integration
and we would compute these deltas and
we'll take a step so any questions for
this slide
menu
so we can also from that linear system
write it out as the Delta X as y as the
inverse of M times some vector v so
that's why we need investment in this
because there's an inverse here
okay so next um the ibms are actually
very okay go ahead
oh sorry
um so appians are actually very robust
in the sense that you can see in this
figure we don't really have to follow
the central path exactly it suffices for
us to stay in some neighborhood of the
central house and it works it's enough
to make progress
and not only that there's also this
observation like along sending
observation that the variables are
changing very slowly in the sense that
the L2 Norm of these Delta steps are
very small and because in generation we
actually don't need to take the exact
step so what we can do is that each
duration we only need to update a few
entries of our Primal and steel
variables that have changed by a lot and
for all the other variable coordinates
we can just let them stay the same so we
can take a very sparse updating
generation
and this means if you see our Matrix M
the only part that's changing m is this
as an X here this means in every
iteration we are updating only a few
coordinates of the Matrix M this whole
idea dates back to Vania in 1989 where
he used this slowly changing and smaller
update idea to get a into the 2.5
algorithm for square dance LP
but in order to even bring it down
further to Fascinations on vacation time
we will need a more clever amortization
scheme and it was first proposed by
kohalien song in 2019
so very roughly speaking this is a very
complicated amortization scheme and it
involves a pretty complicated proof
behind it but I won't be able to cover
any of them
but I will say that we can view this
amortization scheme as follows so in for
any J from 0 to log n over 2 why is this
login over 2 here because then 2 to the
J is just rooted I'm thinking about
we're taking rodent iterations
so for every two to the J there will be
a update of size 2 to the 2J in average
J iterations so let me show you in this
diagram so for for J equals to 0 that
means in every single iteration we will
receive a uh update that changes one
element and then for J equals to one it
means in every two iterations we will
receive an update of size 4 and then for
J equals to three it means in every four
iterations we will receive an update of
size 16 and so on and so forth okay and
then as a sanity check so we know like
what is the update that we receive in
iteration let's see what is the
accumulated updates that we receive up
to let's say the force iterations so
this will be just a sum of the actual X
like they're exponentially growing so
they will the last term will be the
largest term so basically for every
until the two to the chase iteration in
total we will have accumulated some
constant times 2 to the 2J number of
updates
okay so any questions for the IPM part
[Music]
okay great so now we're ready to design
the data structure what we want from the
data structure is that in every like the
updates of M will follow from this
amortization scheme and then in each
iteration we wanted to Output a vector
that's M inverse times B okay so now I'm
ready to present you with the statement
of the data structure and then I will
prove the same of the data structure and
then we'll see how to apply it to
combine it with the amortization scheme
okay
so the data structure is that there is a
data structure that supports the
following two operations for embalance
matrices
the first operation is an update
operation where we wanted to update the
inverse of M to M plus Delta where Delta
changes K entries and I claim that this
takes team at K time where tmat here is
denotes the fast Matrix modification
time for multiplying and by a matrix and
an unbike K Matrix and I should mention
here in fact inside this notation the
order of the three numbers doesn't
matter so and then k equals to NK and
then everything that's from the
literature of fast Matrix modification
so I will use it pretty Loosely in my
talks sometimes I'll change it to nkn
but it's the same number
and the second operation is a query
operation where we don't actually
perform the update but instead we will
have some small update on the Fly and
then we just wanted to compute The
Matrix inverse times the vector and I
claim that this is cheaper than the
update operation it only takes K Omega
plus and K time and as a figure here
whenever we're going to compute the
update we actually add these updates to
our Matrix and then we compute the new
inverse Matrix but when we are going to
perform the query operation we don't
actually add them to the Matrix we just
compute it on the Fly and another
diagram to think about is that there we
have this maintained Matrix M and there
is the current M that gets updated in
every iteration and then we accumulate
all the changes in the Delta and only
when we have accumulated enough updates
in the Delta we will actually perform an
update operation otherwise we just use
this query operation on the flag there
will be some threshold and today where a
is smaller than one that will be set
later in order to balance the running
time of the two operations
okay so next let me tell you how to
implement these two operations it's
actually yeah
I've been getting exactly or just we are
maintaining it exactly and you don't
encounter Precision issues uh there are
other papers that will deal with
Precision issues but I'm not gonna cover
that in my talk here yes
in numerical analysis people say that
you should never explicitly communicate
in most Matrix and to quote from his
first lecture if you're maintaining a
members explicitly or doing something
wrong
you know uh do you think it's uh is it a
problem American one
I don't think it's a problem here just
because we're in the high Precision
regime instead of using those iterative
linear systems solves here
so we are already in the high precision
we're assuming fast matrix
multiplication and you're not assuming
it is very much a theoretical result
analysis results
let's trust me
I'm wondering
I think there's a recent paper analyzing
the big complexity of all these
operations and it shows that I think you
go out and buy something like polygon
factors and all other results
yeah and another way I think about it
from you around Express here
um is that it sort of corresponds to the
case where you have very eo-conditioned
system and you want to solve those media
systems in that case all the iterative
method will depend on the conditional
numbers but they are not better than
just compute the universe yeah just to
make a quick comment to reconcile the
the things between the talks I guess um
if you just want to solve a linear
system then you maybe don't need to
fully form the inverse and if you have
better approximate representation that's
helpful it's like synergistic with
students to jumpstop and even here we
want to Sullivan plus Delta and we're
not exactly forming the M plus Delta
inverse you know it's keeping track of
certain low range characterization of it
so maybe that's the exclusively stored
at the end of the day right
right and that's why I'm wondering you
know maybe there's a way of representing
it not exclusively
if we're explicitly from the whole
universe there'll be an extra like N
squared from just writing it down
uh yes but like when you're a party you
just quite an elements from it right so
I would argue this is not explicitly
maintaining the inverse
connection between
I mean
continue with how to implement these two
operations
um so for the update operation
they first make this simple observation
that because Delta only have K non-zero
entries so we can write it as some low
rank decomposition U times c times B
where u and v both take some columns
from the identity Matrix
okay and then we will just directly
apply Woodbury identity to it and the
hard part when competing with very
identities is the second term so what
are these matrices so they are actually
very simple because you and we are both
like sub Matrix of the identity Matrix
so M inverse u v transpose time M
inverse and this middle Matrix they are
all just sub some sub Matrix of the
Matrix that we already maintained so we
can just read them off uh and then so
this
term here will correspond to this figure
here and the bottleneck to compute this
equation is when we are in the end
multiplying the two rectangular Matrix
together and that would take t-mat and K
and time as what I promised on the
previous slide
and then next
for the query operation it's very
similar we again write Delta as this
formulation and then we again use
Woodbury identity but now we don't
actually update the inverse Matrix
instead we only wanted to compute the
vector so we'll use the maintained
Vector that we have on the right and
then we write it out as this
so now the most time consuming steps are
two steps the first step is that when
we're Computing the smaller inverse in
the middle which half size K by K so
that would take K to the Omega time and
the second step is that now we have this
Vector on the right so we just do Matrix
Vector multiplication from right to the
left and then when we're multiplying
some Vector with this big rectangular
Matrix that would take an K times and
this is the query time that we promised
so the update time this is the current
time so now we have this investment and
data structure let's try to apply it to
our APM from this amortization scheme
so what does the algorithm do the
programs what I explained previously so
the algorithm will maintain the inverse
of some Matrix M and it will accumulate
all the element updates in this Matrix
Delta and then when Delta has
accumulated more than n to the a entries
we will perform an update operation and
otherwise in generation when we're
running the IPM we just perform a query
operation to Output this Matrix Vector
product
so what is the time of the update well
we just compute the amortized time so
there are because we only actually call
this update operation
um when you have more than into the a
number of uh size of the update so we
can sum J from a login over to because
this exactly corresponded to the 2J
equals to n to the A and then up to J
equals to log n over 2 and this is the
cost of the update operation and then we
can amortize this over 2 to the J
because it happens in average two so the
J iterations
um and then there's this property that
this function is actually a convex
function so we only need to sum the two
terms on the two ends the smallest term
is one J equals to a log n over 2 and
this is T mat into the A and we can
amortize it over into the a over two
iterations and then for the other end
it's when this term this term is n so
it's team that's into the Omega and then
we amortize that over wooden iterations
so this is the amortized cost of update
and for query it's much simpler because
we only perform an inquiry when your
update is smaller than today so we just
plug in k equals to n to the a here and
this is the query time okay so now we
got this update time in this query time
we are trying we wanted to balance these
two terms by setting the parameter a so
I need to provide a little more
background about fast matrix
multiplication here
so there's this fast matrix
multiplication exponent omegas that are
already used a lot which is the running
time to multiply to square matrices and
then there's also this view exponent
which is denoted by alpha alpha is the
largest constant such that multiplying
and by n Matrix with an unbike into the
alpha Matrix takes a unsquared time so
the smallest like it's very trivial that
you can multiply a matrix and a vector
in N Square time but actually Alpha can
be much larger than that there has been
very active research until like this
year so if it's currently the best Omega
is about 2.37 and the current Alpha is
about 0.32
so when we're using these algorithms we
just set a equals to Alpha so that this
team into the a will be unsquared and
then we just plug in them into these
equations and then the dominating term
is until the Omega minus half tier and
then multiplied by the total of wooden
number of iterations this gives the
clean result that the algorithm will
runs in the current matrix
multiplication time but there is no
reason to believe that these numbers are
the true numbers because you can see I
this comes up this year
but we do know that in the ideal case
Omega should be at least two because
that is your input size and Alpha should
be at most one so what would we get if
there are like in the future when there
are more improvements for fast Matrix
modification and in the ideal case
we can balance these two terms by set a
equals to 2 over 3 and both the query
time and the update time equals to n to
the one and two over three and that will
give a total time of until the 2 and 1
over 6. so there's still a gap here of
size one over six and we can actually
improve this to 1 over 18. but before I
go on to that and using a more
complicated inverse maintenance data
structure so before I go to that data
structure
um there's one little detail that a kind
of high tided under the rug previously
which sets the entries of V are also
changing so what to do
um
so there are some different papers that
use different techniques to deal with
this in the original paper by Cohen lien
so they just use some sampling technique
on the vector v to make it have only
written number of non-zero entries so
that whenever you're multiplying them it
only takes into the 1.5 time which is
very small
uh and there's a later follow-up paper
by lisno and jump where their techniques
that you can use the sketching Matrix
that Michael talked about in his
lectures
um which have size written times and so
it also sort of decrease your size to
root and times and and it will take
until 1.5 times as well and I should
mention because you're we have already
in this inherently adversarial setting
so they need to refresh the siachi
Matrix in every iteration
and then later there's a paper by brand
where he made these algorithms
deterministic because if you're doing
something or sketching they are
randomized by nature and his observation
is that the vector v actually follows
the same amortization scheme as the
Matrix M and then he he says that we can
write the slightly larger
Matrix with v so that's the vector that
we care about M inverse we would just
show up in the inverse so we can
basically just use the data structure I
described previously for the slightly
larger Matrix and then in the end you
just read off this column in this Matrix
and more generally in a later paper by
the same author he showed that actually
for any Matrix function that only
involves plus minus multiplication and
inverse we can rewrite it as the inverse
of some larger Matrix so this inverse
maintenance data structure can actually
be used to maintain any Matrix function
that only uses
okay
um so why am I saying these techniques
because they are also useful when we
wanted to further decrease this one over
six factor and let me continue to that
now
um so the one number six Factor can be
further improved to 1 over 18 it was
first thrown in the paper by myself and
saw and Weinstein jump where our
technique is a two level projection
maintenance data structure and we also
need to use the sketching technique on
the previous slide and then we also need
to generalize the amortization scheme to
two levels but later in the paper by
brand he showed that actually we don't
need to do two level in projection
maintenance because of the Matrix
formula that I just described on the
previous slide so it actually suffice us
to use the two level inverse maintenance
in the previous paper by brand and some
of his other co-authors
um
so let me describe this two level
inverse maintenance data structure here
so high level Lee what does it do
previously we were maintaining some
Matrix and then we have the current
Matrix M but now instead of just
maintaining one Matrix they will
maintain a second Matrix that sort of
have a smaller distance between the
current Matrix
and then the first Matrix is maintained
explicitly same as before but the second
Matrix is maintained implicitly so it's
more efficient
and then we will have the update
operation to update the first Matrix and
the query operations are still the same
but there's also a operation that I call
partial update to update this middle
Matrix let's maintain implicitly and
then now we will have a new threshold
that's smaller than the previous one to
the a which is into the B threshold so
that later we will be able to balance
between these three operations to get a
better trade-off
I won't be able to go into the details
about all the data structures but I do
wanted to mention what do I mean when I
say this Matrix is maintained implicitly
n so it means we are maintaining some
transformation matrix T which is defined
as the Matrix such that M2 equals to M1
times B times T it was first defined by
sankovsky in so it's a very late paper
about two decades ago
um so why we wanted to maintain this
transformation matrix because then when
we're Computing the inverse of M2 it's
just equals to the inverse of the
transformation matrix times the inverse
that you already maintained so it
suffices to if we have this
transformation matrix we already have
this new inverse
and then we can compute the closed
formula of the transformation matrix
and the observation is that because I'm
M2 minus M1 is very sparse it have at
most into the a non-zero entries so
together after multiplying with m y
inverse here this Matrix will only have
at most n to the a non-zero columns it
has some structure here
and the inverse of the transformation
matrix preserves that structure so the
inverse of the transformation matrix
also only have until the a non-zero
columns and when I say we maintain M2
inverse implicitly what I meant is that
we actually only maintain the inverse of
the smaller Sub sub Matrix even though I
won't go into details why that is
efficient but I hope you can at least
see just from this formula here that the
part that's actually being immersed is
exactly the sum Matrix the other part
it's you'll see two here so it will make
it more efficient okay so I also won't
give the exact statement of the data
structure but I will just give the
application of this data structure to
our LP problem so the update time is the
same as before and then we get the
second level partial update time
um I think I hope it should sort of make
sense to you because previously we sort
of get this amortization over root into
the A iterations and now we'll get this
amortization over root into the B
iterations for our smaller threshold and
then the query time also improves from
the previous query time which was into
the one plus a
and then the root end here comes from
the sketching technique that we were
using because it's sort of equivalent to
your reading written entries
okay now let's try to apply them so in
the ideal case we have two parameters we
can balance now we'll set a equals to
eight over nine and b equals to two
stars
and then all of this running time equals
to enter the one and five nice and they
will give the total running time of 2
and 1 over 80 another
so the natural question you should have
in mind right now is okay can we try to
further generalize this data structure
to more levels
um to make it more efficient well first
of all there are some technical reasons
why this might be hard one is that we
are already maintaining the second level
Matrix implicitly and it's it's kind of
hard to imagine how to do it even more
implicitly in the third level and more
levels and second is that we are already
using this sketching technique that
reduces the dimension on the left and
then we also exploit the sparse Vector
update on the right so we do need those
lower dimensions on the two sides and
it's a little hard to imagine where is
the third side because you only have two
sides of the Matrix but not only because
of that there's actually more evidence
that it really might be hard to
journalize this more I will be very
careful about the conditional around
here because it is not a lower amount
for the lp problem itself instead we are
using this data structure applying it
for the lp problem and then we can also
apply this data structure to other
problems for example if we only allow
element update and element query in each
iteration is a different it's different
numbers of updates and queries it will
also give different running time for
example you can see it's amortized over
into the a iterations because you have
element wise element update
so there is a conditional lower Bound
for this data structure that apply for
element update and element query in each
duration
uh oh and I should also mention so this
data structure not only have application
in LP it also have application in many
other problems for example many graph
problems yes
so I'm saying we are maintaining it
implicitly it's not the same as C2 sorry
uh so when I say we maintain and
pleasantly maintenance means like this
C1 universe
my notification might be a little
confusing C2 is just the other the name
of the other block
so it can be used for many other graph
problems as well one application is that
you can achieve a into the 1.41 update
inquiry time for dynamic reachability I
think in the fine grain complexity talk
we mentioned this upper bound but
without giving any proof so now you know
how to get it by using the two level
inverse maintenance data structure
uh and then there is a conditional lower
band based on the hinted umv conjecture
um that exactly matches the upper bound
so this is a lower Bound for the data
structure itself so maybe we can still
do something better for LP because we're
considering a different problem and we
also allow more approximations there but
it's unclear so this is just some
evidence that this might be hard okay I
will talk about the lower bounds in more
details in the third part of my talk if
I have the time
um okay and then before I move on to the
second part I also wanted to just
broadly go through some other data
structures that are also used for
similar problems
the first one is for flat LP which is
also a very important problem so for the
flat LP the current best running time
happens dependence n times D so it's
linear even and it means that we cannot
afford to have gluten iterations and
also have some costs that's linearly in
every single iteration so for these
algorithms we don't use the previous log
area that gives the rooted iterations
instead there's a better
um
barrier designed by Leanne siford
released it for barriers that will give
us root d iterations
and not only that in order to get this
linear dependence on and we also cannot
afford to use the sketching technique
that we talked about previously which
will reduce the dimension to root n and
then you get into the 1.5 cost
deterioration but that's already more
than linear so they will need to use
some Vector maintenance on the left to
do this more efficiently and get rid of
the limit like more than linear
dependence on them so there are a lot of
data structures here oh so because the
leases were better use lose weight so
you also need to maintain those loose
waves efficiently there are more data
sources there and then for the graph
problems there's also like first I would
think about them in some sense as
special LPS because this sort of this
LPS where your Matrix the love flushes
and there are all the techniques to work
with laplacians and for other structured
LPS for example for LP with small tree
with there are more specialized
algorithms for that that can achieve
linear time to solve the lp when the
tree with is small and for other chronic
programming problems the universe also
have other structures that can be
excluded by other data structures I just
wanted to give you a sense that for
different organization algorithms you
need to really see what is the special
structure of the optimization problem
and try to define specialized data
structures for that okay
so next let me see let's move on to the
second part of my talk which is about
dynamically stickers regression uh so
this slide is to introduce this to our
regression but I think it's already
covered in Michael's talk earlier today
so I just wanted to remind you this is
the problem formulation and we have the
closed formula and if we wanted to
compute it exactly it would take n times
detail minus one time but some often
we're happy with a proximate solution
and then we can use other sketching
techniques that we covered in details
and then in the end we can achieve near
linear time in the input size and we can
even reduce the dependence on Epsilon to
logarithmic instead of polynomial
here today we will consider a dynamic
least squares regression problem
we're in this setting the rows of a and
the like rows of B are arriving one by
one online so this is the incremental
setting
um so there are in total a number of
iterations we should think about and as
much larger than these think about as
polynomial indeed
and our goal is to dynamically maintain
maybe approximate version of the lead
Square regression problem with minimum
updates the sort of models this continue
learning setting where you already train
some model but you're continually
receiving new data points and you don't
want to retrain your model from scratch
whenever you get new data you wanted to
update it more efficiently
and let me introduce some notations we
will use small a to the T to denote the
new row and we will use capital A to the
T to denote The Matrix up to the t is
wrong
okay so first of all if we wanted to
solve it exactly what do we do this
actually dates back to the control
literature where they call this common
filter and the idea is simply just apply
Woodbury identity to the normal equation
where there's this inverse and it would
take D Squared time to do an update so
over an iterations it will take in this
work time but we know that for the
static problem we can improve this to
near linear times in the input size can
we also do this for the dynamic problem
as well well the answer is yes we can do
this
for the for the incremental updates we
can get a running time that's roughly on
the a plus some polynomial factors in D
and in one over Epsilon and if you
remember such a pro gives this whole
talk about working with adaptive
adversary so we can also make this work
for the Adaptive adversarial setting but
we will need to increase from D cubed to
D to the fifth
um
okay so this almost matches the offline
solution when and is very large and I
should also say like d to the 3 here is
kind of natural because in the offline
you would get D to the Omega but now
we're in the online setting so you get
the cube it's sort of the same as what
we would conjecture from OMB conjectures
okay and then how do we get this data
structure
well one thing is you might want to try
to just use those sketchy metrics that
make them Dynamic but it's a little hard
to do this because the sketching Matrix
would depend on every single row that
you have in the Matrix a so instead we
can use the sampling technique lower
score sampling so this will be the third
time in this week that you've seen this
leverage score something but let me
remind you what are the definitions I
think it was covered in great details in
sushan's talk earlier this week so when
we're in the graph settings the library
scores are called effective resistance
but it's called Lower scores for
generations and they're all the same
thing
so they are defined as for the eyes
Library score of a tall Matrix a is
defined as the ice row times this
inverse and then the transpose the
transpose of the ice the transverse of
the ice row here and then you can also
think about them as the diagonal entries
of the projection Matrix
and intuitively the library scores
measures how important a bro is for the
row space of a so for example if the
largest war is one it means if you
remove this row you will decrease the
rank of a by one and if all the rows of
the Matrix a are the same they will all
have the same battery score and we also
have some good properties the first one
is between zero and one and the second
one is that the summation of all the
library scores equals to the rank
and then using large words we can do
this large score sampling it is
equivalent to how we get this
spectral sparsifier for graphs and we
remember to give the proof of this
statement here for graphs but every
single part of his proof would carry out
for General matrices as well so if we
sample the ice row of this Matrix with
probability
Library score divided by Epsilon squared
we will get a Absalon approx spectral
approximation between D A and A
so in expectations we use this largest
sampling we will sample D over Epsilon
squared number of rows and because we
are just sampling rows we don't really
mix them this is very cheap to dynamize
and that I will show in the algorithm
here oh
foreign
so what we do in the algorithm is that
when a new role arrives
so first of all we will maintain some
approximate version of the exact Matrix
and then when the new row arrives we
first compute the approximated version
of the online leverage score
and then we just flip a coin with
probability this lower score divided by
Epsilon squared as required by the level
score sampling
and if we sample one then we will add
this row as a new row to our maintained
Matrix and then we update it using
blueberry and otherwise we just ignore
this row and then throw it away
okay so if you see this algorithm there
are two steps that are expensive the
first step is when we're Computing the
lowest score it would take D Squared
time in the worst case the second step
is this update so let's first ban the
running time of the Second Step because
we don't do this update very often we do
it pretty we only do it when we are
actually skipping a row
um so there is this Lemma in the
paperback hohan musco and another author
I don't remember her name
um
or they say that the sum of these Online
Library scores also is roughly the up to
some logarithmic factors
so this means even though we are
sampling in an online fashion so it's
not exactly the same as laboratory or
something but still the approx the
expected number of rows that we keep
still D over Epsilon squared so in total
we only do this update operations D over
Epsilon Square times and each time we do
this update it takes D Squared time so
this gives the D Cube term that I
mentioned in those statements and this
is very small if you amortize it over
probably a number of iterations
and now second is how to compute this LR
score efficiently
um so this will use a JL trick that was
first observed in the paper by Spillman
and survascala
for graph settings but it will also work
for General matrices so the JL Lemma
says that there exists some JL Matrix J
that is that compressed from Dimension D
to login so it's a very small
compression such that it can preserve
the L2 Norms of fixed and vectors X
um
okay and then the observation when we're
Computing the library score is that this
is the definition of some lower score
you can write it out as a L2 Norm
so what we do is that we not only
maintain the inverse Matrix we also
maintain a straight out sketched version
of the inverse dimensions and whenever
we're Computing The Leverage score what
we do is that we actually just use this
compressed smaller Matrix multiply this
with our new row factor and then compute
this out to Norm and it will be a good
approximation for the laboratory itself
and then so basically it will just take
login time because that's the size of
your JL sketch and times the number of
non-zero entries in the row so this is
the running time to estimate it and that
gives the first term
um lnza in the stated running time
okay
um
finally I wanted to add the slide about
for adaptive adversaries just because we
had the other lecture note so I wanted
to make some connections so there are
two parts why this is not currently
working for adaptive adversaries the
first part is definitely this JL matrix
it's a random Matrix so you're leaking
Randomness and the second part is that
the online library score something
itself is not adversarily robust it's
because the next row you receive the
adversary could see whether you have
kept a row previously so the next Road
it gives to you can depend on that
information in order to attack you
um so previously in sushant's talk where
when he was proving these lyrics were
sampling Lemma he said that we will use
Matrix turn off around but now in order
to make it work for this adaptive
sequence we will use the Matrix turn off
around for marking chaos and there
exists such results
but sadly it's not there's some subtle
subtle issues that makes it not as tight
as the simpler Matrix external fan so we
will need to sample with a higher
probability so it needs to be e times
the virus for
um and then in the end this means we are
keeping D Squared the number of rows
instead of the number of rows I think
it's an interesting question to see if
an improve this can match the oblivious
case
and for the second part to make the JL
trick and recently robust I think it
would fall into the unique answers
template
um that such a pro talked about
what we do is that we just make the JL
estimate and overestimate so whenever
the Matrix doesn't sample a row it's
actually equivalent to how the algorithm
would behave if the algorithm doesn't
use the JL Matrix because from the
output bit point of view you are not
stamping any rows you're just doing the
same thing so it's a unique answer and
whenever we actually sample a row that
is when some information could be leaked
about this JL Matrix and that at that
point we will renew the JL of sketches
of discard the previous geoscache and
renew our two fresh randomness
okay
um I think I'm running out of time but
is there any question for the second
part
let's say what about uh why only you
engaged only one of the road samples
you mentioned that uh
because otherwise you can imagine I'm
running two algorithms in parallel the
first algorithm is the one where we
compute this thing using the jlcatch the
other one is I don't use any GL sketch I
just compute it exactly and then when
you are not sampling any row both
algorithms won't be sample any row so
they will perform exactly the same so
it's nothing
yes yes
okay
um so
you're saying when you pick it you
relate it by what you sampled by in that
leak sweaty sample like
when you're talking about the scale part
IES
yes so when you're sampled
it doesn't really leak very strong
information it's only a one or zero
information but maybe because you're
using the JL sketch you're sampling from
a slightly larger probability that you
don't use it but you could be making it
okay
she'll provide some matching lower
bounds for the two upper bounds that I
talked about
uh and then both of these lower bounds
are going to be based on when we
conjecture or variance of the OMD
convection let me remind you the
definition of the OMD conjecture so
first it's about the online Matrix
Vector multiplication problem where in
the beginning we're given some Matrix
and and then in each round we are given
something vector v and then we wanted to
compute the product of this Matrix with
the vector
and the conjecture states that there is
no algorithm that pre-process the Matrix
in poly and time and it achieves and
less than N squared amortized aquarium
there's no such
um
so roughly what it means is that in the
offline setting if we wanted to multiply
a matrix with n vectors we can use fast
measures multiplication to get into the
Omega time but if we wanted to do it
online then we cannot do it better than
a cube time so it also says that the
only way to speed up Matrix Vector
multiplication is by batching
so there are many
conditional lower balance for dynamic
problems especially for dynamic graph
problems that we can improve on using
those conjectures some of which you
already seen into an India's talk
earlier this week
uh I also want to say it also implies
that the oumb conjecture is also
Hardware in the oum reconjecture you are
not only through the vector main
generation you're in a u and a V and you
only one that could output a scale which
is U transpose MV even that is hard and
it's the same lower bound okay so now we
know the conjunction let me first tell
you a variant of this conjecture that
can be used to prove a matching lower
Bound for the inverse maintenance data
structure
um this is called a hinted UMB problem
um there's slightly more complicated let
me go through it with graphs so in the
beginning you're given not only a matrix
M but some vectors some rectangular
Matrix U and some rectangular Matrix V
of size and by until A and N by n to the
B this into the A and then the V will
exactly match the into the a n into the
B threshold we had in the upper bound
and then in the second phase you are
given some index set of the rows of M
in the third step you are given some
index.j of the columns of the Matrix m
and then in the last step on the you are
given two index I and J and then we want
you to Output the umv product of the ice
row of U and the sub Matrix of M and the
J's row of V
and the conjecture says that any
algorithm must do one of the following
three things which are all the naive
things that you can imagine the first
thing is you do some pre-computation in
phase two you just multiply this Matrix
U and the sub Matrix of M in phase two
or if you don't do that then in phase
three you need to do some
pre-computation that multiplies U and
the sub Matrix FM and V together so
whenever you do this pre-computation
later you can read up the solution
easily so if you don't do any
pre-computation then in the fourth step
you just have to compute this Vector
matrix multiplication naively which
would take into the a plus a b time
so this conjecture is definitely
stronger than the omery conjecture but
it sort of captures the same intuition
behind which is the only thing you can
do to speed up computation is by
pre-computing everything or you have to
do it in online fashion where there's no
other acceleration you can do
so to apply this let me first write out
the upper bound that we have
um you can already see they sort of
matches and the proof is also very
simple it's basically if we wanted to
solve this hinted um reconstructure
using the inverse maintenance data
structure we can just add some diagonal
matrix identity Matrix in here and in
here and then in each phase you just
either perform it into the a update that
updates into the like add unto the a
number of ones here or you perform into
the B update that adds into the B number
of ones here and then if in this last
phase you just do a query
so this means there's a lower bound that
adds up these three terms together for
the balanced cost of all these three
operations and that matches the into the
1.41 operand that I described for many
graph problems
okay so this is the
lower Bound for inverse maintenance and
finally I just have one last slide
um about the lower Run for the least
Square regression so if you see this
upper bound here you notice some
different difference between the static
case one case is that we have polynomial
dependence on when our absolute instead
of logarithms dependence so can we do
better but we show this lower Bound by
the OMB conjecture that actually no if
you wanted to achieve very high accuracy
it will require these squared time so
you cannot get the amortized time
periodation and another thing is that
this upper bound only works for
incremental updates it what about fully
Dynamic update where you have both
incremental updates and decremental
updates so the answer is also no so even
if you just wanted to maintain some
constant approximation you will need to
use D Squared amortized cost per
duration okay so finally I'm ready to
end my talk I'm just going to slightly
go over these three takeaways the first
one is that we've already seen there are
many Dynamic data structures that can be
used to improve the cost for iteration
of organization algorithms and for
different algorithms we need to design
specific specialized data structures for
them and then there are second things
that many Dimension reduction techniques
randomized techniques are very useful
because often we allow approximations in
the optimization algorithms and the
third part is that sometimes when your
upper bound is stuck it's also an
interesting question to think about the
lower bound and we have this omv
conjecture which is is by nature pretty
algebraic and it's very sometimes it's
very easy
suitable to apply that for our questions
okay thank you and I'm happy
[Applause]
thank you questions
okay so two questions so first of all is
it is there any chance to improve the
exponent on D in the online online
squares regression like from D Cube to
maybe due to the Omega or something like
that
um we don't have any explicit lower band
but I think it would be hard because I
my intuition is this D Cube fits with
the
one
and the other question is uh I mean I
guess things change significantly when
you simultaneously adds not only rows a
row but not also a column do you think
that there's any chance to get anything
interesting in that regime
I have never thought about it
I'm not sure what we would get okay
thanks
a few more questions
all right let's think again
[Applause]
all right so